han sido múltiples lanzamientos que
llegaron desde la frontera norte hacia
ciudades de alta Galilea en el norte de
Israel precisamente la mayoría de estos
lanzamientos se fueron interceptados por
la cúpula de hierro el sistema de
defensa
contra misiles de Israel pero algunos
lograron caer en espacio abierto dentro
de Israel o incluso generaron algunos
daños Menores en ciudades y una persona
como al menos resultó herida por restos
de uno de estos impactos obviamente
cuando los lanzamientos vienen desde el
Líbano lo primero que se piensa es en
hezbolá pero de momento ningún grupo
ha asumido la responsabilidad de estos
lanzamientos el canal ala la Villa del
canal de Arabia Saudita exitó Fuentes
volada señalando que el grupo libanese
no estaría detrás de estos lanzamientos
sino más bien crece la teoría de que
pudo haber sido alguna facción Palestina
que actúa desde desde esa zona del
Líbano
fue en la previa estos lanzamientos
emitir un comunicado solidarizándose con
los palestinos por las incursiones las
dos noches de incursiones de la policía
israelí en la mezquita de alaxa de
manera consecutiva y el grupo gépolá
dijo que iba a apoyar todos las medidas
que decidieran tomar los grupos de
palestinos en este respecto se espera
nuevamente que estas tensiones hay que
estar vigilantes a lo que suceda sobre
todo esta noche porque luego de dos
noches consecutivas de de incidentes y
también de lanzamientos desde la franja
de gaza la atención está alta y de ahí
también que el gobierno israelí haya
decidido convocar a su gabinete de
seguridad liderado por el Primer
Ministro Benjamín después de casi dos
meses sin reunirse esta noche para
analizar la situación de seguridad tanto
aquí en Jerusalén como lo que está
ocurriendo desde casa y desde el Líbano